good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you're very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on sky news
the tory leadership battle filling the
front pages this morning after some big
beasts were knocked out yesterday for
failing to secure enough backing from
mps one of those the transport secretary
grant shaps will be here in just a
second his own dream of being pm over
now he wants to fulfill the former
chancellor's dream of getting the keys
to number 10 by backing rishi sunak
someone who thinks that's a bad idea
jacob reese mogg will also be on the
programme we'll also speak to another
contender nadim zahari with us earlier
on in the week as you remember after he
made the ballot paper voting due to
start at lunchtime
some exclusive polling as well to bring
you on how labour is gaining ground on
the government it's wednesday the 13th
of july
doomed to fail a warning to tory
leadership contenders from business
leaders about their ambition for tax
cuts as the list of candidates is
reduced to eight
and that list will be whittled down
further this afternoon when mps vote in
the first round with the results
expected around five o'clock
planning your summer holiday will reveal
which airports and airlines are the
worst for cancellations and delays
i've never murdered anyone i've ever
raped anyone
what am i in jail for
people don't believe it they think i'm a
serial killer
a message from behind bars britain's
most notorious prisoner charles bronson
leaves a voice note for our crime
correspondent as he tries to receive a
pardon
77 minutes of horror the new footage
that shows a police officer
sanitizing his hands as a gunman in
texas
kills school
the sri children president has fled the
country for the maldives i'm in colombo
and i'll have the latest on the crisis
ambulance alert how the heatwave is
stretching our emergency services we'll
talk to the boss of the welsh ambulance
service
also to come on the programme for you
this morning wherever you're watching us
right around the world
i'll be asking a meteorologist here at
reading university why is it so hot how
long is it likely to last and if we
could expect more sizzling swimmers in
future
[Music]
and a galaxy far far away queens brian
may and 10cc write a song for space as
the nasa telescope reveals stunning
images of the universe we'll speak to
graham goldman from 10cc
[Music]
good morning everybody teasing promises
of tax cuts has become a theme of this
tory leadership campaign as the list of
candidates running to replace boris
johnson is whittled down to eight but
there's a warning this morning from
business leaders that this approach is
doomed to fail that from the cbi who's
also doomed to fail in their leadership
ambitions the first round of voting
opens this lunch time and we'll know
which candidates have been knocked out
by around 5 p.m let's take you through
who's left should we here we go
the current front runners are the former
chancellor rishi sunak who we understand
already has the support of 47 mps penny
mordant currently has 28 mps publicly
publicly
backing her with liz trust slightly
behind with 22 the other five contenders
still in the race are tom tugan hat the
current chancellor of dim zahawi kemi
badanok jeremy hunt and zoella bravaman
now out of the contest at the transport
secretary grant chaps she'll be with us
shortly the former health secretary
sergey javid and raymond shisty who all
pulled out of the race in the run-up to
yesterday's deadline after failing to
secure enough nominations we can also
bring you this poll shared exclusively
with us this morning which suggests
labor has increased its lead over the
conservatives since the cabinet
resignations the figures from the
polling company delta polls suggest the
labor lead over the conservatives is now
10 when looking at voting in tension
across these three parties 56 of those
who voted tory at the last election
think mr johnson is doing badly in his
job of the mandate often quoted by boris
johnson the 14 million who voted for the
conservative party at the last election
only 8.5 million would actually vote
that way if there were a general
election
tomorrow
grant shaps is here morning morning how
are you nice to see you thanks for
joining us on the program um what
happened
in terms of your campaign yeah so i came
here obviously very late in the day and
um but uh got off to a good start the
rules were then actually changed uh they
doubled the nomination figures from um
previously in order to speed through the
competition because we're keen to have a
new leader in place i would have uh been
nominated on the old rules i thought
probably not on the new rules um and in
any case uh looking at the candidates
talking to all the candidates as i was
doing throughout i actually came to a
conclusion that another candidate had
the right policies and could
be certainly be ready to do the job on
day one as he walked into downing street
and that's of course issue
politics is brutal though isn't it isn't
it
how do you feel about it this morning um
you know i uh very much enjoyed my time
in the race i think i came and spoke to
you here on no nothing
sophie sorry on on sunday very
i was in the studio on sunday and uh as
i say you know i enjoyed the uh race i
was able to put forward my platform i
would have on the previous rules uh been
nominated
the uh the the rules were switched uh
but as i say rishi uh has a good plan
which it was closest to the things that
i was saying in terms of the need to
tackle inflation the need to grow the
economy
and so on i was pleased to back him and
here we are well you say that but let me
just remind of our viewers a couple of
things that you said and tell me why
you've now uh folded in behind rishi
sunak um you pledged to halt the planned
rising corporation tax cut income tax by
a penny and spent three percent of gdp
on
uh defense um
at the time which is called those sort
of pledges fairy tales and arbitrary
times yes he wasn't calling that's but
he was other people's the generality but
let's just sort of look at this politics
is of course about finding the best
route through and we're grown-ups you
have to look at where compromises exist
he is raising uh defense spending to two
and a half percent i said three he's
raising it to two and a half from two
two point three at the moment uh he is
planning to bring down corporation uh
sorry uh uh uh private individual tax
you know the basic rate uh from 20 to 19
piece who was doing that albeit that i
was saying or couldn't it be done a bit
quicker but he is moving in that
direction he has just this week last
week delivered the biggest tax cut that
we've had for a generation uh with um
you know a a huge change in the you know
that we've got the highest national
insurance for 70 years
yeah absolutely we've had the we can't
really you know we've had the only um
pandemic that we've had for over a
hundred years and yes it's added cost to
it that's true but i mean you're you you
okay so even if you're saying that
you're you're trying to do a similar
thing he was saying it was a fairy tale
to try to do it in the time scale that
you and others have suggested yeah so we
had there was a range wasn't there just
to explain this there was a range of
different uh you know manifesto
commitments and some people saying they
would go a lot further and a lot faster
uh i was saying probably something in
between those candidates and what rishi
was saying and so as i looked around
pretty logically i'm looking for the
person who is closest to my position and
actually i thought had the credibility
to do it and i think the reason that
rishi has both of those things is that
he recognizes as i did
that inflation is the biggest single
issue that we must tackle at 10 it's
extremely high and the first thing to do
is to tackle that the second thing to do
is to go further with tax cuts and as he
said yesterday when he launched it's not
a question of if there will be tax cuts
there'll be a question of when there's
tax cuts and that's rishi's policy and
again i thought that was the right and
responsible okay rees-mogg says he's a
socialist i mean he's saying it as a
that's a dirty word um what do you think
look i i think it's best if we just
concentrate on the positives for each of
our um candidates and avoid sort of uh
perhaps others wouldn't agree but in
this context quite extreme language
well i mean clearly a guy who
you know is fiscally conservative uh
wants to get the debt and and deficit
down and debt falling as a proportion of
the overall economy i mean the idea that
this is you know so this is clearly not
true but as i say i i think and this is
what i'll be doing um
throughout this campaign it's best to
focus on what you have to offer now
uh
jacob is supporting a different
candidate um she'll be able to say what
she supports rishi can say what he
supports people the membership will
eventually make that judgment and i
think that is far better than trading
sort of you know uh disparaging comments
as this was intended what do you think
about suggestions that we should
withdraw from the european convention on
human rights uh well look the european
conventional team writes something that
we helped set up um has uh its purpose
uh i haven't specifically spoken to
arishi about the issue but i don't think
that it would be
a an early priority the main thing is to
get the laws working as we need them for
us to make a better life for the people
of europe the only people that are not
in it are belarus and russia i think
well that's as i say well i don't think
it's part of
any platform here just to just to
clarify what so um what then well let me
ask you about nadine doris first of all
um she's talking about
dark arts and dirty tricks your
campaigns always split the party don't
they well look a leadership campaign by
brutal by the very nature again
of course do you have the potential to
um bring out differences on the plus
side when they're done well and we've
seen this happen before as well when
cameron and david davis ended up
battling it out in the final it was
actually a very good process for the
party ideas were brought forward people
said by the way i remember that campaign
at the beginning of the campaign oh this
is going to be brutal oh everyone's
going to be sort of bashing the heck out
of each other in fact that's not what
happened in the end i think here the
same will be true of course
sometimes they'll be you know lively
debate but in the end
i think you know and i certainly know
this will be the case with rishi he will
put forward the positive case others can
put forward their case what's wrong with
with offering votes to others you know
why is that such a bad thing
as somebody quite close to you quite
recently once said there's the brakes
well look
simply in this case it just didn't
happen i think the the idea was are you
sure yes the idea and not only am i sure
the person that was suggested which was
jeremy hunt
himself says every single person on his
nomination paper is somebody who's very
close to his campaign so even he's
rubbished it look again i don't want to
let's just focus on the positives i i i
okay let's do that then talk to me about
rishi sunax that's very slick video how
long do you think it took him to cut
that um i i don't think he personally
cut it at all but i know it wasn't
filmed until wednesday so he'd already
resigned okay and and he wasn't planning
to be prime minister until he resigned
he hadn't got a campaign up and running
he didn't have people in the background
working for him he didn't have an office
well i what i what i think is is the
case is that he was becoming
increasingly concerned about the uh
uh direction of of travel there had been
a
long series of missteps as far as he was
concerned and i i don't think it would
make sense to pretend otherwise we know
that was the case um but uh you know in
terms of the video as you say in terms
of sort of actually pulling the campaign
to together uh that part of it is um
from from post his resignation i know
specifically the video was filmed on
wednesday okay on wednesday i'm sure not
all of it was um i'm sure not all of it
was well there was stop there was stock
footage in there from the 1960s you're
right some of it already exists yeah and
other stuff had been filmed before as
well that they didn't knock that
together in such a short period of time
unless you can prove otherwise uh well i
i think i'll come on the filmmaking come
on and tell me exactly
the challenge
i know how to make telly i know how to
make those movies and it takes a little
bit longer
all i know is especially wrote to
johnson
uh last week questioning his competence
his honesty and his seriousness then
yesterday um he said you know he's the
best thing since sliced bread so why is
he doing that why is he changing his
look
again i think that um it's clear that
you can both be
brilliant as an individual and also be
flawed and as rishi pointed out as i
pointed out in many times actually over
the last year or two um you know boris
johnson was a is a brilliant individual
who did many remarkable things including
getting us through this brexit nightmare
that we lived through but not six years
prime minister anymore doing the the uh
the vaccine uh what's happened with uh
with the ukraine and the way that he's
been the one one of the principal
leaders in the world but you know
obviously made mistakes and you know
like all of us you can both be great and
flawed and i'm afraid it applies to
every single one of us
there are no exceptions to that are
there no there are not however being
prime minister um it would appear that
he still has quite a lot of grassroots
support and so rishi sunak has been
reading the runes and thinking i need to
not knife him in the back anymore
look i i just don't agree with that at
all rishi
myself others we all work very very
closely with the prime minister and even
right through to um to to to close to
the end to try to pull things round to
try to rescue a situation which over a
period of time well in the background he
was organizing his own campaign just in
case well look look look as i say um you
know your particular allegation about
the video i think is is wrong but we'll
see you know
all i know is rishi sat down and
recorded it on on on wednesday as i
understand things um but clearly
anybody could see that there were
problems anybody could see that things
were going wrong that does not detract
from the fact that boris johnson has
been remarkable in many ways and it's a
huge sadness to many people many voters
myself included as a member of his
cabinet that he wasn't able to pull
around and as you know i personally
thought that despite
you know some
issues misgiving some shortcomings uh i
actually thought uh his advantages
outweighed okay the uk ambassador to
ukraine sat where you are last week and
said they're going to crowdfund to have
him in ukraine because we don't want him
very well well i know i speak to my
opposite number uh alexander kubrickov
who's the infrastructure a transport
minister in in ukraine and he's a huge
fan of boris johnson but even more so
he's a fan of the way that this
government has responded to ukraine and
i'm one thing i'm absolutely sure about
is if rishi and i imagine even other uh
people were elected ukraine would be
front and foremost of their plan in fact
rishi's a bit busy
funded 2.3 billion pounds to that battle
talk to me about um our infrastructure
uh what on earth is going on with our
airports and airlines well i've been
very concerned about the way that the um
their bounce back or over bounce back in
in a sense from cove it has caused all
those cues and con and you know
problems at the airport i've been
working with them we've got a 22-point
plan
that we've put together with the sector
which has included changing the law to
speed up things like the processing of
uh
of security clearances using some brexit
freedoms as it happens
and ask the airports and the airlines to
be realistic about the program that they
run the flight program that they run
all in order to ensure that when the
schools break up for the summer uh
across the whole country and they
already have in parts in scotland for
example
that we see the airports run as smoothly
as possible that i should point out this
is not a uk only problem with the same
issues
my viewers care about that okay i don't
care about what's happening
which country which airport do you think
according to our data that we've just
done which airport do you think is the
worst i can't let you just dismiss the
international nature of it aircraft
which
do you think is that well i can because
it's my program okay you can't because
yeah aircraft flight around the world
what do you think is the worst effort i
have to finish this point aircraft fly
around the world and when they do the
delays of other places also create which
do you think is the worst airport in the
uk well several airports have had
problems manchester has been very well
published i i i don't know which is the
worst depends how you measure it depends
okay if it's passionate who do you think
cancel motion
again you tell me if you've got a number
it will depend how you you judge it we
know that manchester's have problems we
know that gatwicks have problems we know
that heathrow of shores and there uh
have lessened the number of flights that
they have as well do you feel that
you've been concentrating enough on
what's happening on our railways given
that you've been running a leadership
campaign absolutely i mean i've been
working so the train drivers are going
on straight now as well well the train
drivers whose average salary median
salary is nearly 60 000 pounds a year
doesn't take away from the point i've
made i i just don't believe that this is
the right time for them to strike the
public everybody watching this every
household pays 600 pounds each to keep
them all in jobs uh and all off furlough
still going out are you gonna do it
better and i don't think that is uh
justified and one of the things which
i've talked about before
is we have to modernize our railways we
can't have a situation where we can't
run services at the weekends because we
aren't allowed to put it in the contract
that sometimes you work a weekend we're
not asking people to work seven days so
we have to modernize the railways then
we'll be able to get a settlement at
sixty thousand pounds nearly average
salary a year i think the public will be
the time we're gonna have to leave it
there we've got lots of things left up
in the air hopefully we'll see you again
very before soon and we'll see what
happens thanks very much indeed thank
you mr
boris johnson will face prime minister's
questions for the first time today since
his resignation you can catch that live
on sky news from 12 o'clock i'm pulling
a double shift today the first ballot in
the conservative party leadership
contest takes place between 1 30 and 3
30 this afternoon as tory mps vote for
boris johnson's replacement we'll have
all the results here on sky around five
o'clock with sophie who looks very much
like me and we have a special program
coming up next week's guineas will host
a live television debate with those who
want to be the next leader of the
conservative party and the country's
next prime minister the event will take
place next monday the 18th of july with
the candidates taking questions from a
virtual studio audience you can of
course be part of the audience if you'd
like to get involved put your questions
to the candidates email news debates at
sky dot uk
right now then let's take you to sri
lanka where there's a developing
situation police have been using tear
gas on protesters at the prime
minister's residence what on earth is
going on
let's take you to colombo nicole is
standing by nicole tell us more
thousands of people have been streaming
towards the prime minister's office this
is one of the buildings that they
haven't occupied the reason they're
heading down the road there is because
they want the prime minister reynold
wickrek singer to resign along with the
president now the president gotta buy a
rajapaksa is set to resign as we know
he's already left the country he's in
the maldives he went out on a military
jet and it's expected that later on
he'll from the maldives head off to
another country so it's
a real d-day here in sri lanka
essentially it feels like this is the
end of the rajapaksas this is what these
people have been demanding for for
months they've been on the streets
they've been enduring hardship the
country's economy has collapsed they're
fed up with it but clearly the the
potential or today's resignation that
we're expecting of the president isn't
enough for them they want him and all of
his cronies out of the country
uh so that prime minister's office is a
bit further down there they've told us
that they're not going to storm it
but tear gas was fired earlier today as
they got closer to it
whatever happens though sri lanka is
still in a dire economic situation the
economy has collapsed as you drive
around the capital colombo it's cues
after cues of people lining up for
petrol for gas for food for medicine and
that's because people say the rajapaksa
family has wasted the country's money
that they've overspent
that they have also made terrible
economic decisions
and they really want to see them out
people are having a hard time
even surviving on a day-to-day basis one
in five people are hungry here right now
and
today we're going to wait and see
whether people
end up celebrating the end of the
rajapaksas whether they eventually
decide to move out of the buildings that
they have occupied in colombo
or whether they continue their protests
on the streets
okay for now nicole thank you
breaking news at home now and the state
of the uk economy and the cost of living
crisis let's bring paul kelso in our
business correspondent of course hello
to paul just hearing from the chancellor
saying he's not complacent tell us about
the figures
yeah perhaps a good thing even he's only
been in the job uh eight days okay but
he has got a little bit of good news no
matter how long he's in that office uh
this morning a surprising uh upturn in
gdp in may the economy grew by 0.5
that's against expectations which were
that things would be stagnant and it
increases on april when the economy
contracted by
0.2 so that growth
in the economy however is from a
slightly surprising quarter it's largely
driven by growth in uh what the ons
calls the health human health and social
care
sector it's a rise in gp appointments
has uh driven this increase uh largest
the largest contributor to the increase
in gdp and that's offset one of the
drags on the economy last in the last
set of figures which was the winding
down of test and trace now you wouldn't
necessarily want to build economic
health on failing human health but it
does emphasize that gdp does look at
economic output in a very broad sense so
how often we go to the doctor counts as
economic activity but every sector has
contributed a little bit of growth in
may production was up 0.9 manufacturing
up 1.4
and construction up 1.5 but there is a
nagging reminder in these figures of the
inflationary pressure which is affecting
people so badly and driving the cost of
living squeeze
retail services and consumer-facing
services are still contracting they're
going backwards so we are spending less
money and ultimately whoever ends up in
the office whether it's nadeem zahawi
beyond his weakened a bit so far or any
of uh whoever the various candidates
appoint is gonna have to deal with this
overwhelming pressure to try and deliver
growth in the economy uh despite the
pressures that we're facing okay for now
thank you
still to come on the program for you
this morning catching up with the brexit
opportunities minister that's jacob
rees-mogg about why he's decided to back
liz tross for the leadership ahead of a
potential vote of confidence in boris
johnson joined by labour's pac mcfadden
and we'll hear about the ways desperate
travelers are getting around the
crippling delays at the passport office
[Music]
i was chatting a moment ago or two
wasn't i about which of the worst
airports which are the worst airlines
the transport secretary didn't want to
get involved with that guessing game but
exclusive research i should say seen by
sky news suggests there has been more
disruption at gatwick than any other uk
airport there have been delays and
cancellations at airports across the
country due to staff shortages
the information shows that up to
mid-july gatwick has cancelled the most
flights proportionally this year it
cancels 3.2 percent of flights 10 times
worse than the best performing uk
airport which was stansted
when it's broken down by airline a
covered affected chinese airline is
worse but british airways is the worst
performing british airline
ryanair is one of the best performing
airlines in the world
and when we have a look back by country
china the us and canada have all been
slow to open up but the uk is the worst
performing major country
in europe
wow he's known as the uk's most infamous
prisoner charles bronson has been behind
bars for nearly 50 years but now his
lawyer is asking the government to grant
bronson a pardon claiming he's reformed
and is no longer a threat to society
here's our crime correspondent martin
brunt
from inside one of britain's most secure
jails a plea for help from its most
notorious prisoner a man who's been
locked up for nearly 50 years i'm 70
years old now martin
17 years old
i've never murdered anyone i've ever
raped anyone
what am i in jail for
people don't believe it they think i'm a
serial killer
the prisoners best known as charles
bronson but now calls himself charles
salvador
jailed originally for armed robbery in
1974 he's been kept in prison with only
two brief releases because of a series
of attacks on jail staff
bronson's solicitor says he's reformed
and is urging the justice secretary to
grant a pardon
in a letter to dominic raab he asks him
to use his prerogative to free bronson
because he says he's made great progress
in prison
he says in the letter the evidence in
excess of the last five years is clear
that his risk of violence has
significantly reduced
the argument is that if he's been able
to demonstrate that he's not violent
within very high risk
situations in custody
towards staff governors etc then the
risk falls away if he's released to the
put into the public because historically
whilst there was a risk to the public
it's never been as severe as towards
prison staff and governors
in 1999 bronson took a prison teacher
hostage for two days he got a life
sentence but was eligible for parole
three years later
he's soon to have another parole hearing
likely to be the first held in public
but his solicitor claims the ministry of
justice has done little to help him
prepare for it there's no independent
scrutiny he decisions are made on him by
people that don't know him
during one period of freedom in an
amateur boxing match bronson
demonstrated his physical fitness
something he says he's kept up
i can still do 95 press ups in 30
seconds so i'm still there
mate
bronson's parole hearing is not expected
until the end of the year
martin brunt sky news
95 press-ups in 30 seconds
looking at some today's other headlines
for you now
mps want renewed efforts to vaccinate
people against covid19 as infection
rates continue to rise the public
accounts committee says it wants to
reduce the number of adults in england
who haven't had a jab from
3.25 million
twitter is suing elon musk to force him
to complete the 37 billion pound
takeover he agreed to in april the boss
of tesla said on friday he was dropping
out of the deal because the firm didn't
give him enough information about fake
accounts
police have made four arrests in a
crackdown on people smuggling gangs the
arrests are linked to two events in 2019
where 32 migrants were found in the back
of a lorry in the netherlands and france
it's the second major operation in eight
days following on from 40 arrests in
raids across europe last tuesday
more than 100 firefighters have tackled
the blaze in trafalgar square in the
heart of central london the flames broke
out in the basement of the admiralty pub
and sent thick smoke billowing around
whitehall there are no reports of any
injuries
thought there for those firefighters you
know how hot it was yesterday and they
had all of that kit on what a great job
they do now newly released video shows
heavily armed police officers hanging
back in the corridor of the robb
elementary school in uvalde in texas
while the gunman was inside a classroom
killing children
he shot and killed 19 and two teachers
in may before he was confronted by
officers more than an hour after they
first arrived a warning that martha's
report does contain gunfire
it's the video the families of the
uvalde victims have been fighting to see
showing for the first time the horror
which unfolded inside robb elementary
school here 18 year old gunman salvador
ramos strolls down the hallway
he walks towards the classroom where he
will murder 19 children and two teachers
a young boy comes round the corner he
survives scarred like so many by what he
saw
two and a half minutes later the first
police officers arrive
two approached the classroom but soon
retreat
their colleagues hang back
they're joined by several more carrying
guns wearing body armor even ballistic
shields
their training makes it clear they
should confront the threat immediately
but in the absence of any apparent
effective leadership they don't
56 minutes into the murderous rampage
another officer stops to get hand
sanitizer
it's another 20 minutes before they
finally enter the classroom and kill the
gunman
for briefed families the video confirms
an excruciating and deeply infuriating
timeline how many more kids have to die
how many before
people start standing up
you think
that oh this doesn't happen to me it
doesn't happen here or anything until it
does
and it will it's not a matter of if it's
a matter of when
we have to do something
to get
to stop these kids dying
with every new detail about this
shooting a community forced to relive
its darkest day and to the crisis
response team demands that their
mistakes be acknowledged martha kellner
sky news
that's pretty difficult to comprehend
this morning isn't it uh at home
ambulance services are warning that
they're being stretched to breaking
point by the current heat wave and
that's likely to get worse as
temperatures rise later on in the week
but we've been told that our summers are
getting hotter so this may be the new
normal shiman standing by for us uh at
reading university for us this morning
which has a world-renowned weather
research division um also to the west of
london where it seems to be always
particularly hot maybe that's because
you're there shaman
maybe maybe that is the case as you say
weather is expected to get significantly
hotter over the weekend but it has
cooled down a little bit today and may
call down a little bit over the next
couple of days as well but over the
weekend sunday into monday there has
been an amber extreme heat warning set
in place for much of england and wales
and although many of us have been
enjoying the sunset sunshine it can have
knock-on effects as well with severe
illnesses as well as disruptions to to
travel as well with cancellations of air
and rail taking place and as you say the
ambulance services are also
set to their highest level of alert too
and that's due to difficulties of the
hot weather and this is all happening as
we're being told that over the next
couple of weeks the temperatures could
surpass record highs seen in
cambridgeshire in
2019 now i'm at a weather center here at
reading university i'm joined by denny
danny mengele he's a meteorologist
student here hi it's lovely to be joined
with you this morning so explain first
of all what exactly is behind us what
are we studying in front of at the
moment because this is the equipment
right that measures the temperature yes
this is a running atmospheric
observatory it takes a weather
measurement such as the wind rain
sunshine and doing that all day every
day for the last hundred years
and i've just reported there that we
could potentially see the temperatures
surpass the highest point that we saw in
2019 is this correct
uh it's very very much possible i mean
some of the 10 warmest temperatures here
on record have come in my lifetime so
it's more than possible it could happen
um
however i'm still you know pessimistic i
don't know what not so
and why are we seeing such hot
temperatures they felt a little bit more
like we're in l.a or the caribbean over
the last week or so why are we seeing
such hot temperatures
um yeah seriously because of um like
global warming climate change um it's
kind of a lot warmer and this can lead
to some more um
warmer conditions and calm weather hours
more tense heat sunlight so
and are we likely to see
this sort of hot weather in future there
and if so should we be preparing more
um if we don't do any action then yeah
it'll tend to happen and then it'll get
worse and this will come the normality
however if things do change we do cut
down on the end users and stuff like
that then yeah bomb it can you know
plateau and even come down so
thank you so much so we will be
explaining a little bit more about this
equipment later on as well as i say
ambulance services are warning that they
could potentially see some issues as the
weather continues to increase over this
weekend so they're asking everyone to be
safe and keep cool
indeed so thank you um just want to
highlight something actually about a
teenager who's died after getting into
difficulties while swimming in a canal
16 year old alfie mccraw went missing in
the air and calder navigation in west
yorkshire police say it's a tragic
incident and urging people not to be
tempted to cool off in open water
despite
the hot weather poor little chap do bear
that in mind speaking to the
mayor of greater manchester in just a
second asking what his authority is
doing to try to protect young people who
are thinking about swimming in open
water when it's just so hot and those
temperatures due to continue
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
very hot again over the weekend met
office have issued a warning an amber
extreme heat warning for much of england
and eastern wales on sunday and monday
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now the front runner for the
conservative party leadership and thus
uh to be the prime minister of the
united kingdom and northern ireland at
the moment as things stand is a rishi
soon then there are two ladies below him
as figures show at the moment that's
penny mordant and also liz trust what
does she think about it
morning morning
is the leadership contest descending
into bitterness
can you really unite after this
accusations of smear campaigns
withdrew from the tory leadership race
yesterday and has now thrown his support
behind the front runner rishi sunak
got off to a good start the rules were
then actually changed they doubled the
nomination figures from um previously in
order to speed through the competition
because we're keen to have a new leader
in place i would have uh been nominated
on the old rules i thought probably not
on the new rules um and in any case uh
looking at the candidates talking to all
the candidates as i was doing throughout
i actually came to a conclusion that
another candidate had the right policies
and could uh be certainly be ready to do
the job on day one as he walked into
downey street and that's of course rishi
politics is brutal though isn't it isn't
it rees-mogg says he's a socialist i
mean he's saying it as a that's a dirty
word um what do you think
look i i think it's best if we just
concentrate on the positives for each of
our um candidates and avoid sort of uh
perhaps others wouldn't agree but in
this context quite extreme language
clearly
a lot of my viewers well i mean clearly
a guy who um you know is fiscally
conservative uh wants to get the debt
and and deficit down and debt falling as
a proportion of the overall economy i
mean the idea that this is you know
socialist is clearly not true
andy burnham uh mayor of graduate
manchester with us now hello to mr
burnham thanks for joining us do you
think that rishi sunak's a socialist
no
certainly not
he's in the newspapers today saying that
he will govern like margaret thatcher uh
if he's elected leader margaret thatcher
laid the north of england low when she
was in government so i think we could
confidently say that levelling up will
be
dead if if he's elected and continues to
uh to to put that kind of approach uh
forward so
um i just think we're looking at a
leadership campaign at the moment though
that
is a bit farcical as your business
editor said yesterday there are two
major crises facing the country the cost
of living crisis and the nhs crisis with
all ambulance trusts now on black alert
what are these leadership candidates
saying about both of those things
they're in a comfort zone and they're
not addressing the issues that are
right there in front of the country and
this person will walk into office and
have to deal with from day one so this
contest i'm afraid is not serious at the
moment and all of them need to put aside
the sort of um the gimmicks and the
and the jibes of each other and set out
how they will deal with the serious
issues facing the country from day one
um do you have any sympathy for grant
chaps because you've been in that
position haven't you uh where you've
wanted to run and be the leader and it's
not come off it is as i said brutal
oh no i do uh it is
it is a brutal process but that is
politics uh and people are putting
themselves forward to to run the country
so you can expect it to be
brutal because you have to be tested
and as i said i don't think these
candidates are being properly tested the
conservative party has to do a job for
the country it has to make these people
say what will you do day one in office
to deal with the nhs crisis now okay
correct me if i'm wrong but has any of
these candidates talk properly about the
nhs over the last few days i've not
heard it and here we are in the middle
of summer with all ambulance services on
black alert what does that mean for the
winter in the national health service
none of them have anything to say about
it so how can they walk in and be prime
minister in those circumstances they
have to be challenged i think it's
revealing today that
none of the above
comes out top when the public were asked
who they want which suggests it's hardly
capturing their imagination and it even
comes joint second amongst tory members
they're saying uh none of the above you
know
they have to seriously raise their game
uh if they
are
genuine about wanting to leave this
country in a couple of months time
yeah um we are planning our leadership
debate actually on monday why is it that
politicians
are always uh cautious about doing um
debates
well to me
i mean you reference labour leadership
elections i mean i have had experience
of leadership elections as you say to me
this feels like a party
that wants to go into opposition it
feels as though it's in its comfort zone
playing to the culture war issues but
not actually addressing the things that
are affecting people up and down the
country your viewers k this morning who
are worrying about their finances who
are worrying about the position in the
nhs this party is not dealing with those
issues it's kind of it's in its own
little world talking to itself and it
feels to me as though it's a party
heading into opposition and actually i i
mentioned rishi sunak a moment ago if i
look at the policies of all of them
leveling up will be dead in the water at
the end of this tory leadership campaign
because they are all talking about major
tax cuts and a much smaller state you
can't put that forward and then be
serious about leveling up the country
and leveling up the north of england so
i would say if that is where we end up
at the end of this leadership election
there has to be a general election
because that is a major change on the
from the manifesto on which all of these
people were elected in 2009
mr mayor talk to me about i don't know
if you heard me talking about that young
lad alfie who um went swimming in a
canal
and um drowned
what would you say to the
people in uh in the northwest
particularly in greater manchester this
morning because we we hear about these
stories every summer don't we
uh
heartbreaking is the only thing i could
could uh
think
really when i saw his picture and you
just imagine what his parents
his family his friends are going through
we've had something similar here uh over
recent times kay there was a young man
who uh sadly died in salford keys last
year uh when he jumped in after a game
of football so we we know uh what
friends will be going through my
shortshare uh this morning you know over
the last five years around just under 50
people uh have died great manager fire
has been called to uh 43 fatalities i
think and across the country i think
there were over around 160 deaths last
last summer so an even hotter summer it
could it could be worse here in greater
manchester we have launched
our cold water campaign
and we have been warning about the
dangers from from june actually uh
because it's the shock that can that can
uh cause uh the the the fatality where
people go into even though it's hot
outside people will go into cold water
in a reservoir or in a canal and it's
the shock to the body that causes the
the problem so it's helpful i guess for
me to be able to say that on your
program this morning okay please look up
those campaigns please promote them
amongst family and friends certainly as
we go through the next few days we need
to be very vigilant
okay thank you mr mayor as always much
appreciated thanks very much
now while the current priority for all
contenders in the concert conservative
leadership race is gaining the support
of the parliamentary party if they are
to reach the final two they will then
have to shift their focus to all party
members up and down the country up to
about 200 000 of them joining us is one
of those members who also happens to be
the youngest sitting tory councillor
harrison almanvarti who has a seat at
elmbridge in surrey hello to you thanks
for joining us
good morning here thank you thank you um
who are you leaning towards at this
stage
um currently it's quite hard to pick i
think there's quite a lot of good
candidates out there uh for me
personally i'm leaning towards more uh
rishi sunak and penny morton i think
that's kind of my two favorites at
current
and why is that
um i think for me um rishi sooner comes
across as most credible uh he's
definitely got the uh i think most
valuable experience he he's you know
managed the country's finances you know
the last couple years so he he gives
them a good understanding we generally
see progression from that stage of
chances into prime minister you know
such as with gordon brown
so i think from an experience standpoint
i think he's naturally best suited for
that role
uh why not list trust
uh for me liz truss uh i think she comes
across well uh but i think when you kind
of look at maybe that older footage for
example like 2014 when she's speaking it
just doesn't really resonate with me um
i think she did a good job as trade
secretary and i think she's a good
advocate of brexit uh but she's just not
resonated with me
um okay and what do you make of some of
the suggestions that is a little bit of
a dark arts campaign going on at the
moment how concerned are you as a young
conservative about the sort of damage
that that does at the top
i think
there's always going to be trouble when
it's i mean the conservative has been in
power
since 2010 and you know it's been a long
time it's between the
two general elections so i think it's
it's always hard to kind of maintain a
squeaky clean uh kind of reputation
because uh when you're so focused on
running the country there's always going
to be you know things that happen so
there is always going to be that
reputational damage unfortunately it's
just how well you can kind of mitigate
that
and and control that and and how you're
perceived but i think when you are in
power for such a long time uh and
especially when it's midterm
there's always is
it's always tough
okay just before i let you go we've got
jacob reese mog here in the studio to
speak to us in just a moment give him
your five second pitch about why you
should be prime minister in the future
why i should be
yeah um well i i'd quite like to maybe
bring a different approach i i think uh
youth and the conservative party go hand
in hand really well uh together so i'd
quite like to maybe bring
those fresh ideas forward
okay it's good to talk to you thank you
mr morgan here with ruth is here um
would you vote for him he sounds
absolutely splendid and so i i agree
with him we need more young people
involved in politics uh but for now
you're going for liz trust why i am why
because in cabinet liz was the most
supportive cabinet minister in getting
breaks to opportunities
and was um
using her role and her chairmanship of
cabinet committees to make sure we could
get the breaks of opportunities through
she also opposed the endless tax rises
of the former chancellor which i think
have been economically damaging i also
was opposed to within cabinet and i
think that's important that you have
somebody who
is fiscally on the right side of the
argument who doesn't believe that higher
taxation is the right answer to every
question
and because i think she's been very good
in leading with the prime minister on
ukraine and making sure we had a strong
response to russia so i think in foreign
policy and domestic policy and european
policy she's got the right answers how
important is loyalty to you extremely
important how long do you think she'd
been campaigning planning her campaign
for well i think lots of people had had
drinks parties with other mps and they
had had um meetings but that's the
routine business of cabinet ministers
even i had drinks parties with other mps
uh when
are they watching for ages no no i don't
think that's right i think that you have
a job as a cabinet minister to meet
other mps so that you hear the views of
backbenchers and understand what their
concerns are as leader of the highest
mind were mainly around issues to do
with parliamentary procedure and so on
but the foreign secretary would
naturally have them
with other members of parliament um to
find out what their views were on
foreign policy
i know
that's the assumption that gets made
it's not setting up a website it's not
getting ready in december for a campaign
to come sometime later that's a
different name quite a long time that's
a different order of magnitude i have no
idea whether she reads the domain name
but
it's
very important that cabinet ministers
whilst they're in cabinet are loyal i
was as you know and am a great supporter
boris johnson and was involved in his
campaign very early on but that did not
happen until he had ceased to be foreign
secretary
um you sailors trust is a strong
brexiteer in fact uh you were in number
10 with nadine doris saying that she is
a stronger brexitee than you and nadine
doris put together did she not vote for
remain
i think you need to look at what people
are doing now it is possible for people
to change their mind
so yes of course everyone knows
elizabated for remain
but what i was saying is within cabinets
it's very interesting
because when we had a
right round on the retained eu law bill
foreign secretary was completely
supportive about getting rid of the
supremacy of eu law and having a sunset
on eu law
the one of the departments that objected
was the treasury which didn't want tax
policy be taken away from eu
interference so you have a department
led by an ostensible brexiteer that was
backing the supremacy of eu law and a
department led by an ostensible remainer
that was backing ending the supremacy of
eu law i think you have to judge people
by what they do currently um to that end
european convention on human rights even
dominic raab says that he wanted to
remain as part of that whereas liz trust
was saying yesterday i believe that she
thinks that we shouldn't be what do you
think well i think
that there's a bill before parliament at
the moment the um
uk bill of rights british bill of rights
which is a sensible way of proceeding
what we need to be able to do
is recognize that the highest form of
law in this country is law made in
parliament that that is
our authoritative law
and that that must be enforced and that
is subject to the greatest of human
rights democratic oversight but the
justice secretary is bringing that
forward and even he has said that he
thinks that we should still remain
within the european community the the
european convention is not in and of
itself a bad document it is how it is
interpreted and applied and the
ridiculous injunction imposed by the
european court stopping the rwandan
deportations which had been approved by
uk courts uh and had been approved by
the uk parliament is not something that
the uk can carry on putting up with
whether you need to come out of it
formally or whether you can get
derogations is a different matter i i
think getting derogations is probably a
simpler way of doing it um nadine doris
who again we saw you with yesterday
accusing rishi sunaka or certainly the
campaign of dirty tricks by lending
votes to jeremy hunt
what do you think i have no idea whether
that's going on
uh or not
if it was
well what we need to do is to get two
candidates to the final round
in a way that the members of the
conservative party can choose i'm
strongly in favor of the
mandate coming from members of the
conservative party
i'm sure that no one would wish to
stitch it up in advance and if they did
i would think that would be improper but
i don't have any evidence that people
are doing that so lending votes would be
inappropriate is how you feel about that
but i'm not making any accusations of
that kind
but you know how it is
with interviews that things can
sometimes get taken out of context later
so to be absolutely clear i have no
evidence that's going on but if it were
going on it would obviously be improper
why do you think he's um a socialist
rashi sooner well now you're referring
things that may not have been said in
cabinet and i'm glad to say there's a
30-year rule actually reduced do you
think he is
i think as a chancellor he made
decisions
that were
of the left rather than of the right
that he was a tax-increasing chancellor
as i said i didn't support the decisions
he made i thought we should have been
looking at keeping expenditure under
control
rather than raising taxes and i think
the corporation tax rise it's bad for
business bad for investment in the uk
the national insurance hike hits
employers
just after we're getting over the covet
problem and makes life harder for
employees when we're in the midst of a
cost of living crisis i think these were
bad tax rises
so many of the candidates that i've been
speaking to over the last few days are
revoking the memory of margaret thatcher
why are they doing that
well because they think she's a golden
ticket
with the membership is she um i think
the memory of margaret thatcher is
highly regarded within the conservative
party and certainly by people like me
and i think many of our members
but people don't always get what
margaret thatcher did
right they have selective memories as to
what she did so i hear somebody has been
saying that
she would not be cutting taxes now the
first thing she did in 1979 when she
became elected they had a budget
straight away which had very significant
cuts in taxation so say margaret thatch
would not have been a tax cut i think
simply wrong but your candidate is even
molding herself in mrs thatcher's image
well margaret thatcher was a great lady
so um um a reincarnation of margaret
thatcher uh is i think improbable but
nonetheless that's a very great lady and
of the eight candidates that are left
which of the ones would you not work
with
well it's a democratic process
and
the party membership must decide um and
i would remain a loyal backbencher
whoever
was elected i believe in conservatism
i'm talking about particularly about
cabinet post would you accept a cabinet
post from russia sooner no of course i
wouldn't i believe his
behavior towards boris johnson his
disloyalty means that i could not
possibly support him um and he wouldn't
want me in his cabinet anyway so it's
entirely mutual oh i'm sure it is yes i
don't think there'd be any question of
him wanting me in his cabinet but i
couldn't support somebody who has been
so disloyal to the current leader of the
party
from inside cabinet and that's that's so
important
um
tom tuggenheart and jeremy hand have
behaved perfectly properly they were
entitled from outside cabinet to make it
clear that they didn't want boris
johnson to continue as prime minister
that that is
a reasonable thing to do but if you're
bound by collective responsibility
you should stick to that um whilst
you're in the cabinet if you don't like
the prime minister if you think he
should be replaced
nadim
sent his letter in when he thought the
writing was on the wall and it was just
a recognition
of the reality that was a matter of
judgment very late in the day we're
almost out of time and sadie javi
deserved his bloody nose then did he
look most sad is a very decent chap he
put out an excellent document uh on the
economy really very strong one um he's
fallen out i don't wish to say
disobliging things about um sajid but he
behaved in the same way rishi soon after
i spoke to him yesterday and said i
couldn't possibly support him on the
same basis good to talk to you thank you
very much always a pleasure always a
pleasure bit early in the morning but
welcome
well you're very kind thank you very
much indeed uh still to come on the
program for you we're going to be
chatting to tomorrow um about what we've
made so far of the candidates and those
that are supporting them and then of
course we have prime minister's
questions at midday today and then
between 1 30 and 3 30 the first rounds
of votes we should know by 5 o'clock
who's through to the next round of the
tory leadership contest and indeed who
is out on the rear stay tuned for more
here on the sky
[Music]